reversed haenam now I should uh I should
say it's reverse chain rules because if
you remember when you are when you will
learn differentiation right whenever you
have a function of a function which is
the other name the chain rule right if
you have function or a function there
are different kinds of functions and
functions right this tree again it is
the new shows logs and we're just going
to color polynomials okay so that just
like there are many different versions
of chain rule there are also many
difference of reverse chain rule so
we'll look at them in turn I don't know
how far we'll get by the end of term
just see okay so where do we use this
when you have something like this let's
call this and okay if I were to share
well okay what is the primitive of F or
what F prime is another way of see you
so capital F okay what's the primitive
function product plus the family okay
now so far we've resorted to just
expanding it out okay the expansion is
good okay and then we just take a term
by term like we normally do okay so
practice it with me right we should be
pretty good at this my tokens video a
couple lessons on it yeah good power
goes off excellent
plus good good and we have to we have to
stay what C is right so that's a
constant or fine okay but if you know
this is okay since the power is two but
if a power is higher it starts to get a
bit of pain right so you know we did
sort of when we had something like this
if I made the power of silence what's
the better one if I make the power 100
okay just like with differentiation
let's work out what F dash is okay so we
can practice chain rule we want to be
able to do this in a way which avoids
the expansion expansion is super
inefficient as this power goes up okay
because this expansion is going to have
a hundred and one terms in it okay so
it's going to go really really longer
then you've got differentiator sorry
anti different yet every single one
that's a pain so let's just rehearse the
way regular chamber
what's the first step that I do yeah
okay differentiate the inside which is
one okay and then I'll do the outside
which works just like a normal one right
so the 100 comes out the front and then
the power goes out yes okay and the one
at the front turns out to be
inconsequential so no problems okay well
let's just consider if we wanted to
sorry if we wanted to work out what the
primitive was instead of the derivative
well so far the way we worked out
anti-differentiation with these guys is
we just turn the previous process
differentiation we just did it in
Reverse
yeah did it backwards so let's try and
do it here this is what I've got right
in this case I brought the power out and
reduce to by one okay and I also I
multiplied by the river at the inside is
that okay so let's try it this way in
rest what's the first thing that I
should do
okay so with with one thing to know
multiplication and division right I can
do them in any order I like because if I
multiply and then I divide or dividing a
month one you'll get the same result
okay so whether I do the inside of the
outside won't matter that much so let's
do the let's do the outside for us
because that's what you guys are seeing
power goes up by one so let's try this X
plus one come in and that's a peasant's
office take us in the powers gone up now
here I multiplied so now it's dead I
Debow okay now I also probably want to
multiply so I divide by the derivative
of the inside right because in this case
that's what I do or I multiply right by
the derivative of the inside so now I'm
going to divide by the derivative inside
which also doesn't have a fact okay so I
really shouldn't
okay so make sense so how would I know
whether I've got it right or not
yeah we've been moving noticing this
right so because anti-differentiation is
just the reverse process
sorry bit naughty I should be able to
differentiate and get back my original
function yes let's just gimme go okay
I'm going to take the derivative of what
I've ended up with over there
okay just X plus 1 to the 101 that's
plus a constant
okay does it work power comes out the
front power reduces by one this is
already there constant disappears
version 101 that looks good no problems
that's pretty good that makes sense
episode 1 okay let's change other bit
let's take an example why what if
it was 2x what do you think what should
we do first you can do it the same water
that we did before
power power up okay if in so many years
of teaching period no one is ever anyway
okay how it goes on right divide by the
new power and I divide by something else
will acted my wife the two to the driven
inside okay
so multiply my turn so I'm dividing by
202 does it work yes no what does it why
is it fast it does where it doesn't it
101 comes out the front and then the two
will also come out the front which
exactly kids are children too because we
went through all the steps now which is
reversible okay